cédric villani se lance dans la course à
la mairie de paris allez avant cela il
s'est illustré en politique aux côtés d'
emmanuel macron et avant encore il a eu
une autre vie
cédric villani évocation ça se trouve il
gagne une notoriété mondiale grâce à sa
bosse des maths son chapeau de techint
égale lâche-t-il deux catégories chapeau
le cas cédric villani n'a pas quarante
ans il dirige l'institut poincaré dédié
à la recherche en mathématiques quand en
2010 il décroche la médaille fields
équivalent du nobel de mathématiques
or massif devant l'ordi millions rien
qu'en soir du bon la valeur de ce que ça
représentait bien plus grande tournée
des plateaux télé pour le mathématicien
mais plus que son cerveau ce qui
intrigue c'est son style
une coupe un peu manga une lavallière
autour du cou et sur la poitrine une
araignée toujours j'en ai plusieurs
j'étais sorti au goût du jour au bout
d'une heure
vite un jour bleu bien loin d'un destin
politique cédric villani arpente les
festivals les lycées les universités
pour vulgariser ses mathématiques qui en
rebute plus d'un mais règles de
communication scientifique communication
tout court commencer par l'émotion avant
de s'adresser au cerveau bien pratique
pour se lancer en politique
d'autant qu'en 2014 bien avant de
rallier emmanuel macron cédric villani
rejoint les rangs d'anne hidalgo c'est
un soutien de poids pour anne hidalgo
d'ailleurs il explique dans le parisien
ce matin qui la soutient parce que son
programme et scientifique notamment
notamment en matière de transition
énergétique
elle brigue la mairie de paris il est à
la tête du comité de soutien de la
candidate
j'ai bien mis un point d'honneur devant
tous les devants tout une assemblée
réunie en soutien hidalgo d'expliquer
que j'étais ni de droite ni de gauche ni
du centre mais simplement du côté de
ceux qui sont bons ça rappelle quelque
chose
en attendant 2014 ils oeuvrent côté de
la majorité présidentielle socialiste
pour une meilleure approche des maths à
l'école et en 2015 avec l'équipe
municipale de paris
il est porte parole de la candidature de
la capitale pour l'exposition
universelle 2025
quiz universelle si le moment où on
réfléchit aux futurs le futur cédric
villani l'a écrit en tant que soutien de
la première heure aux candidats macron
puis en tant que député la république en
marche avant de se lancer à la course à
la mairie de paris quitte à se brouiller
avec le parti qui l'a fait monter
[Musique]